où
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans le 7-8 journal
toute la rédaction de tv soit 118 se
joint à moi pour vous souhaiter le
meilleur pour cette nouvelle année tout
de suite l'essentiel de l'actualité
locale de ce jeudi 2 janvier 2020 hausse
du smic baisse de plusieurs impôts
disparition progressive du plastique
elle c'est une tradition à chaque 1er
janvier apporte son lot de changements
les détails avec marylène iapichino plus
de bâtonnets en plastique mais en papier
pour le coton tige en accord avec la loi
biodiversité ces derniers sont interdits
à la vente au 1er janvier les
commerçants en six mois pour écouler
leurs stocks
autres mesures environnementales une
distance minimale de nom et pendage de
produits phytosanitaires entre 5 et 20
mètres autour des habitations doit être
respectée
quant à votre logement les ménages
modestes pourront bénéficier d'une prime
versée par l' agence nationale de
l'habitat pour l'engagement de travaux
de rénovation énergétique
la prime rénove peut couvrir jusqu'à
deux tiers du montant des travaux
c'est la promesse phare des manuels
macro gilet jaune une baisse de 5
milliards d'euros de l'impôt sur le
revenu ce qui représente 350 euros de
gain annuel moyen pour 12 millions de
foyers et 180 euros pour 5 millions de
foyers déjà lancé en 2019 l'exonération
de la taxe d'habitation se poursuit
80% des foyers sont concernés en 2020
toujours dans la volonté de diminuer la
consommation de tabac en france
le paquet de cigarettes augmente de 9
euros 10 à 9 euros 20 selon les marques
pour le paquet de 20 cigarettes
objectif pour le gouvernement un paquet
à 10 euros fin 2020 le timbre connaît
lui aussi une augmentation de ses prix
un euro 16 pour le timbre rouge et 97
centimes pour le vert le groupe la poste
explique cette hausse de tarifs pour
compenser la baisse des volumes de
courrier il fait beaucoup parler en ce
moment avec le projet des réformes des
retraites le statut de cheminot
disparaît pour les nouvelles recrues de
la sncf
il continue cependant à s'appliquer pour
les cent trente et un mille personnes
qui en bénéficient actuellement
enfin une revalorisation du smic de 1,2
pour cent pour les 2 3 millions de
bénéficiaires
il est donc désormais de 1219 euros nets
soit 15 euros de plus par mois
il s'agit d'une augmentation légal lié à
une hausse de l'inflation
487 c'est le nombre de personnalités
figurant dans la nouvelle promotion
civile de la légion d'honneur
parmi les promus figure la directrice de
l'institut d'études politiques de
saint-germain-en-laye céline braconnier
elle a été élevée au grade de chevalier
on rappelle que cette distinction
récompense des personnalités pour leur
mérite au sein en de la nation le
passage à la nouvelle année est
également synonyme de nouvelle
résolution
selon un sondage faire du sport perdre
du poids et arrêter de fumer arrive en
tête
et vous quels sont vos résolutions pour
2020 on vous a posé la question
oui je vais essayer de demander en
fiançailles de ma copine donc c'est pas
c'est mon ma résolution est mon
mon petit truc de l'année je pense donc
donc voilà
non rester en bonne santé
et puis surtout qu'ils aient la paix un
peu partout parce que là ça commence à
devenir inquiétant encore quelques jours
de vacances pour les enfants avant
qu'ils ne reprennent le chemin de
l'école alors pour les occuper le centre
alfred de vigny à voisins le bretonneux
organise jusqu'à à demain un stage de
dessin
l'occasion pour ces enfants de 6 à 12
ans de développer leur créativité au
tour du renard et du cerf aux moyens
d'aquarelles et d'encre de chine
marylène ya pichenot a assisté à la
première séance on travaille sur des
animaux un peu d'automne d'hiver et on
va travailler sur différentes techniques
qui vont choisir ce qui les intéresse
l'idée c'est qu'ils soient à l'aise
aussi bien avec le crayon qu'avec
qu'avec la couleur je suis en train de
dessiner un renard au crayon à papier ce
que j'aime bien les renards et jamais à
me faire mes animaux préférés
j'aime bien reprendre confiance en soi
se reconstruire malgré une situation
difficile grâce à la socio-esthétique
c'est le rôle de valérie maillot elle
vient apporter son aide à des personnes
en difficulté dans les yvelines
son portrait est signée manon varaldo
reprendre confiance en soi se
reconstruire malgré une situation
difficile c'est le rôle de valérie
maillot socio esthéticienne elle
intervient chaque jour auprès de
personnes fragilisées par la maladie le
handicap la détresse sociale ou la
vieillesse
ce n'est pas un cours de cuisine qu'elle
prépare mais valérie confectionne une
crème de jour avec les résidente de
l'ephad qu'on dit 6 cuillères d'eau et 4
cuillères d'huile continuer jusqu'à tant
qu'appui grumeaux c'est une reconversion
professionnelle pour valérie maillot
j'étais fonctionnaire à la poste en
parallèle j'ai passé le ca paix
d'esthétique et avec ce bagage
je voulais me spécialiser en fait dans
quelque chose de plus humain
elle devient socio esthéticienne et créé
il ya un an et demi la douceur de valve
fait des grandes respirations c'est la
rose de damas pour la confection de la
crème la rose de damas lutte contre le
vieillissement cutané et l'huile
d'avocat permet en effet protecteur et
restructurant guérir autrement sans
médicaments c'est un des rôles de la
socio-esthétique qu'on sème donc on se
fait en douceur ses soins de beauté de
bien-être font oublier le temps d'un
instant la solitude pour ses résidentes
et vieille dame que nous sommes devenus
son temps même laissé des femmes ça nous
permet de nous retrouver entre nous et
puis aussi d'avoir des contacts on perd
un petit peu valérie poursuit ses soins
elle se rend au centre médico social de
mantes la jolie elle retrouve plusieurs
personnes du groupe d'entraidé mutuelle
vivant avec des troubles psychiques
pour l'huile d'olive en plus voilà une
cuillère au programme de cet atelier
gommage nourrissant pour les mains moi
j'ai pas envie qu'on serre la main de
talent pour remédier au petit pot et ben
on met de l'huile tous les jours et
après vous allez masse est d'accord
laissant ses soins de beauté et de
bien-être font oublier pour un temps les
soucis du quotidien
faut prendre soin de nos mains on n'y
pense pas tout le temps voilà parce que
des fois on n'a pas trop le temps non
plus elle la confiance séverine ne l'a
plus suite à une pelade elle a perdu ses
cheveux pour la mettre en valeur valérie
procès d'un test de colorimétrie la
colorimétrie s'est basé sur le autres du
corps c'est vraiment des couleurs qui va
refléter sur ton visage pour apporter de
l'éclat la socio-esthéticienne met en
valeur les yeux verts de séverine elle
commence par redessiner ses sourcils
puis vient la phase d'hydratation et
apprendre à valérie débute ensuite le
maquillage ne tire pas parce que si on
étire en fait on étire la matière jose
pas cet atelier permet à séverine de se
sentir un peu plus forte et de
reconstruire son image
voilà s'appropriait des gestes pour que
ça devienne une habitude être enfin
femme lors de cette séance séverine
accepte de regarder enfin son image
suite à une pelade j'ai perdu mes
cheveux
navx donc fait une procédure déjà
première procédure pour une prothèse
capillaire et la basse et d'acceptation
du beau moi me maquiller pour faire
ressortir la femme que j'avais enfoui
depuis bien bien bien longtemps et que
je pensais qu'ils n'existaient pas en
découvrant le changement opéré par cet
atelier de socio-esthétique l'émotion
envahit séverine un sourire qui n'a pas
de prix la socio-esthétique à un premier
pas dans la reconquête de l'estimé de
soi c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi de mort vous retrouverez
wilfried richy aux commandes de cette
édition
je vous souhaite une excellente soirée
[Musique]